this week we see the launch of one of
the most anticipated open-world video
games of recent memory and also Mad Max
hi Peter Brian hey doing good nice soft
lob for you yeah doink
GameSpot's very own Chum Bucket how you
doing my friend no harpoons and
publishers you put out games I don't
love sure or love or you just come to
work not wearing any clothes disheveled
and just I'm over through getting shirts
on me yeah thanks sure do tell me about
doom ask me about doom No yeah look
people seem to think I hate Mad Max I
don't there are parts about it I really
like that world looks amazing apart from
a few framerate issues which I'm pretty
sure will be patched out the game just
is rendered so well and when you're
driving which is one of the best parts
of the game in terms of gameplay things
are moving so fast and the action is so
hectic and you have a lot of tools at
your disposal and you feel you feel like
you're participating in a Mad Max film
you know you get the sense that like
there's this movement and speed and
chaos and grit and grease you're right
in the middle of it and that's awesome
so what is it that doesn't work there
are a few things that don't work I'm
gonna start with I think the most
obvious thing that's on the screen right
now is the handing hand combat
regardless of the game Mad Max is not
known as a character to get into
fistfights but this combat doesn't
really seem suited to the game either
you know a lot of pension attention was
paid to car combat and that is
definitely the most exciting but then
you have to go do these things where
you're you're fighting enemies and the
combat system is very reminiscent of
something you'd find from other Warner
Brothers games like Batman or Middle
Earth shadow of Mordor where you know
you mash an attack button and enemy has
an icon above their head when they're
going to attack you either a Vader block
this is a very simple system that while
I think many people accept it and that's
fine and maybe they enjoy it I don't
because for me if I can exploit it by
literally sitting there and tapping my
fingers like this yeah to win a battle
there's no challenge I'm not being
rewarded or making good use of my time
yeah and I think the nuance of that is
lost on some people where I remember
when you told me that and you were like
literally saying you don't even need to
look at the screen you were just hopping
it and there was like videos before of
like how in shadow of mordor that same
thing was the case but that was with
like a high spec character who I like
very specific things unlocked this is
like right at the gate the combat has
just never really gets any better than
that no I mean you do you unlock new
skills for max but you don't really have
much control over them they're just more
contextual things that happen when an
enemy is say to your right or your left
but you're just pressing square and they
just happen to be there at some point
you know an enemy will throw and unblock
an will move your way but then you just
tap the right shoulder button and you're
safe and you can go back to doing what
you were doing and I don't think an
extra variable that calls for one button
like twice in a fight really makes the
combat that much more interesting it's
as I said my review it's too simple and
dumbed down and it doesn't add anything
to the experience it just feels like a
waste of time and it's like something
there to pad out the game it sounds like
it's just a lot of like boring stuff you
need to get through sure tell me about
the like missions themselves the quests
is there are they interesting is the the
sort of core like loop of what you're
doing in the game is that fun so you
spent a lot of time driving around the
map getting from one location to another
typically to take down a camp or remove
like sniper posts or something and the
the reason you're doing this be is
because you've made an agreement with
the chief who's sort of running the
region that you're in and you're trying
to lower the threat from enemies against
them and so by doing that they then
agree to help you get a new part for
your car this story is driven by I need
a new muffler I need a new engine you've
got to get that grill man like that is
seriously every story beat is that
you're trying to build this car the
magnum opus yeah and the game requires
you to have certain things there was an
early mission in the game where you had
to have these specific parts before I
got there I had unlocked better stuff
I'm gonna hide it on my car but I
couldn't continue the mission until I
downgraded to these parts so is this
weird sort of function of forcing you to
get parts for your car by making you
play some pretty boring stuff and a lot
of that is going into camps and doing
like fistfights with guys and basically
clearing the camp right and and when
you're doing those activities you're
collecting resources such as scrap and
maybe you want to save this part for the
question-and-answer but I'm happy to
talk about my issue with scrap right now
if you like yeah actually
if I didn't pick out one specifically up
but like one of the things that people
were there's a couple of there's a
couple of likes or points that people
have actually interesting enough when we
were talking about this before people
thought that you were being too picky
whereas actually the criticisms of your
review seem to be very picky in their
own right one of them being that like
the fact that you the infantry system
seems a bit cumbersome or that you can
carry too much stuff so like talk about
that so everything that you purchase you
purchase with scrap which is basically
shorthand for metal that you collect
around the world and no not any metal
and it's not like you can just say hey
no one's using that fence I'm gonna take
that and trade it in you got to find
these little piles of scrap that's fine
you know whatever I can get past that
part because that's a little gamey thing
and gave me things exist in a lot of
games you know like such as The Witcher
which is someone pointed out to me like
well you can carry so much stuff in The
Witcher nobody complains not that much
well yeah I mean but the difference here
in Mad Max is that the world alone is a
world that's built on limitations and
how well-equipped you are to overcome
those limitations and the game imposes
this notion on you by limiting the
amount of bullets you can carry yeah
right things like that like forcing you
to get water you know to survive I mean
it is a game that tells you you need to
struggle for survival hmm but it also
tells you I need you to go out and
collect piles and piles and piles of
metal and you can carry even though you
can't carry a few more bullets yeah now
maybe I should have put that detail in
my review I realize I neglected to sort
of show a counterpoint to what I was
saying which is why I think it's a
problem beyond it is being inauthentic
but is because the game tries so hard to
sell you on the worlds authenticity and
then when it's convenient for the
gameplay to support this open-world
structure it doesn't matter anymore and
if I'm trying to buy into this story
which I think this is the story is more
important to this game than anything
like the car combat is great but really
you're motivated by the events at hand
they want to believe in the world if
you're going to spend all this time on
it yeah so if I want to believe in the
world and the game is is imposing
limitations on me to make me believe in
it but then throws those away when it
makes sense for itself that's when I
have a problem I don't have a problem
with games that are steeped in fantasy
and never try to address the fact that
you know everything must be logical but
this game tries so hard to put logic
behind everything except when it it
could mean it's inconvenient for the
game man I got a bunch of questions here
then add to that
point Jonnie Webster asked viateur
what's the ratio of time spent on foot
as opposed to in car thanks dude
yeah you spend a lot of time in your car
there is the option to fast travel which
i think is [ __ ] in a Mad Max game
because this is all about traveling from
one point to another you know finding
opportunities of discovery both good and
bad and so to fast travel is sort of
negating the danger and threat of
existing in this world anyway back to
the point you you drive quite a lot the
on foot stuff is really only when you
get to a base and to get there you have
to drive so there is a lot of great
stuff that that's where you're in a car
and I really enjoyed those moments again
like Mad Max is a great game when it
comes to driving I may not have
excellent controls necessarily but the
action and this sort of the thrill you
get is definitely there yeah I got that
when I played some at Gamescom but then
when I had to go in and actually clear
at a base I thought okay this is a bit
cumbersome and boring and but one of the
things I found particularly are the bad
when you're talking about the car combat
because so much of it involves like
using cars to kill people is the fact
that max is able to take a hit from a
car oh yeah like a hundred miles an
errand doesn't hurt oh yeah yeah so I
can go into a base and get into fight
with some dudes and and before I
realized how exploitable the system was
I was trying to play along with it right
like do what it wanted me to do and I
noticed okay I got hit hit a couple
times and all of a sudden was like wait
I just died from like that third guy
hitting me mmm I remember getting run
over by a car rapidly and being fine you
can get hit by a car and you lose about
a tenth of your health and grated now
you can do this too you can do misty
flips all day long off you time your
jump properly understand them you can
stand in fire the rules of this game are
so wait wait wait not that far not but
not every fire that's the thing the game
doesn't teach you what technically it
it's silly like the I don't I don't know
how you can justify any say well it's a
video game dude it's like yes I guess I
get that the video games have rules
elements like that remind me of like you
can very easily if you are a fan of this
game just ignore that stuff and it won't
bother you whereas if you're not in the
position to do that if you're not
feeling like that's it's justifiable
that you can like not carry weapons when
you can carry all this [ __ ] or that you
could get hit by a car but get killed by
three punches like that's gonna be
[ __ ] irritating especially if the
game isn't entertaining which it sounds
like it's not it sounds like a lot of
the missions are laborious and there's a
lot of them to do there are
whew where it sends you to the sort of
far-off corners of the wasteland and you
go underground and I really do like
those because you're exploring things
like a derelict Airport for example
which is kind of interesting and you end
up like walking through a huge jetliner
that's all broken down and there are
these like red-eyed enemies that kind of
scurry about in the shadows and like I
like that sense because it's building
the world but then you fight him and
it's the same old combat and yeah it's
you're literally just doing a fetch
quest so you're going to clear out a
dungeon more or less and some folks were
giving out that there was some sort of
spoiler about the ultimate ending
climactic fight perhaps okay maybe it's
not the fight I described comes towards
the end of the game it is not the final
conflict but I really have to ask people
if you're playing a Mad Max game which
is built around car combat and there is
a main antagonist do you not expect that
you're going to enter into car combat
with that antagonist I just want people
to think critically about this because
while I may have given away an element
that happened in the story if you were
surprised I'm sorry but but I imagine
that anyone who understands what this
game is and who the characters are but
that's not surprising and I didn't talk
about this story by the way I talked
about a battle that you get into I was
telling you earlier it's like you know
you play a Final Fantasy 7 it's like
telling your buddy you fight Sephiroth
he's like laughs I know I'm actually
like everyone in the office will attest
to this I am the most irritating person
when it comes to spoilers like it's like
the amount of like times I've been like
that when people were talking about
innocuous details but until dawn but I'm
I have often like rallied to the
community when it comes to when there as
well Kevin was a frequent spoiler or in
the streets and stuff all of the [ __ ]
time and and sometimes in his reviews as
well but even I found out to just be a
little bit too much considering it's not
actually yes the the ultimate ending of
the game yeah I mean I don't tell you
the outcome I don't all I do is say you
enter into car combat later in the game
when the main bad guy who knew I I'm
sorry I'm a little bit disappointed
because it looked like Mad Max who's got
like it seems like I've sort of a by the
number you know what this looks like
actually it looks like the type of
open-world game which if it came at five
years ago probably would have been fine
yeah but we're graduated like this is
the year that The Witcher 3 can match
this year the Metal Gear Solid's the
final paint comes out and obvious
we don't like merit other games against
other games but like the goalposts
change yes like you know if a game like
infamous was to come here which this
kind of you know mirrors some aspects of
it seems and like we wouldn't address it
the same way in fact where we have Mike
my hardly on the couch last week talking
about Gears of War or Jeff Grossman on
giantbomb having Gears of War one two
out of five a game that he adored like
this is what happens is that like what
we expected these types of games changes
and and I guess you can see why if some
people have lower expectations or they
want to love a game so much then they
get particularly harsh and when they
when they see critical assessments not
landing where they wanted them to yeah
and I want to say other outlets other
reviewers gave a lot of praise to Mad
Max and where I didn't enjoy it and have
a lower something in some get it lower
yeah you know I mean and that's the
nature of reviews I have my own opinions
and so do you out there and like that's
great I don't think we should really be
critical of each other for having
opinions and frankly my opinion of this
game is that it there's too much stuff
that is not developed enough or thought
out well enough to make it that
interesting and enjoyable to play but
the stuff that I do like the car combat
the world itself some of the characters
that's excellent and I think if you have
the time and you're interested in the
game that you should play it for those
things just expect that it's not going
to be all great Peter Brian thanks so
much going on always really appreciate
it stick around we're gonna talk to you
a little bit about other open-world
games above you watching at home here
live or via YouTube GameSpot and whatnot
let us know what you think about Max our
view is up on kake.com you can go check
it out there and let us know if you're
playing the game what you think of it do
you agree or do you disagree stick in
the comments
[Music]